[Musique]
voilà je suis d'un corps principal du
collège bourbon où je fais mes études et
je vais vous raconter l'histoire de
l'éducation
après la départementalisation
anciennement c'était l'école normale où
je fais toutes mes études à cette
époque-là l'éducation s'ils étaient
basés sur sur une certaine discipline
par exemple payer vous tous les matins
les élèves étaient rangés dans ce sens
et on attendait que les professeurs sort
de la salle pour venir prendre des
élèves et durant ces années d'économies
on nous apprenait la pédagogie comment
enseigner et c'est comme ça que j'ai
débuté pour la première voie à trois
bassins est
mais ce qui m'a plu quand j'étais à
trois bassins site et la simplicité des
enfants gentillesse riboud et puis la
cordialité entre les collègues on
n'était pas nombreux on n'était que cinq
ou six le professeur qui est quelqu'un
qu'on respecte et on voit un gendarme
arrivé et tout de suite on on se tient
correctement on voit un professeur à
rêver bonjour monsieur c'est le respect
je trouve que anciennement on faisait
même but travail et l'intelligence
maintenant tout est trop informatisé
l'homme n'intervient plus maintenant
c'est la machine qui fait tout et ça je
regrette je voudrais qu'on ne connaît
qu'on ne réfléchit plus
koné donne plus son opinion c'est la
machine qui décide
l'homme est là pour dire ok on appuie
sur un bouton du résultat ce label est
cliché de pleins et de déliés
on n'en trouve plus maintenant ce sont
des des touches qu'on appuie sur une
machine et la lette apparaît sur l'écran
mais apprendre à écrire correctement on
ne récompense plus le travail fait par
l'élève avant relève travailler parce
qu'ils savaient qu'au bout il y avait
une récompense c'est ce fameux prix
d'excellence prix d'honneur avez-vous
allons travailler pour les avoir
ils ont la chance de pouvoir travailler
dans les conditions idéales mais ce que
je conseille aux hemmes aux enfants
maintenant si d'avoir un but un but dans
la vie et pour atteindre ce but il faut
qu'ils cherchent les moyens pour les
atteindre
[Musique]